c'est un lendemain de tempête de février
à Saint-Jean la vie elle est toujours
aussi belle même sous la neige
daniki est à la tâche mais il prend
volontiers une pause quand on lui
demande ce qu'il pense de l'entente de
force avec le Québec
je pense à tout l'argent qu'on pourrait
faire en ce moment
il en rit tellement il trouve
la ridicule
ne touche que des miettes des revenus de
ce barrage qui est sur son territoire
j'espère qu'on pourra commencer à en
profiter d'ici cette dame
malheureusement pense dan hiki les
négociations à l'époque ont vraiment
avantagé le Québec l'entente semblait
bonne au début mais Terre-Neuve et
Labrador c'est vite senti prisonnière de
ce contrat d'une durée de 65 ans il n'a
qu'un seul client Hydro-Québec elle ne
peut pas indexer ses prix et Québec
refuse qu’il passe sur son territoire
pour transmettre son électricité vers
d'autres marchés
l'amertume on la sent partout même chez
les gens venus d'autres provinces Michel
Savard et néo-québec il vit à
terre-neuver labrador depuis 40 ans
que
ce serait le foie
déjà sont amères envers
il trouve que que le Québec a profité de
la situation
est une mauvaise foi pour
ce qui est de renégocie le contrat alors
qu'il aurait dû être négocié renégocier
le contrat la province a essayé
plusieurs fois depuis 1969 sans jamais
réussir Québec a toujours refusé et les
tribunaux en conclu qu'il n'y avait pas
d'obligation de renégocier je serai à
Terre-Neuve labrador jeudi vendredi pour
commencer à renégocier le contrat de
Churchill phrase à partir de 2041 et
voilà que François Legault entre en
scène lui
pas tant pour faire plaisir à
Terre-Neuve et Labrador que pour
décarboner le Québec l'entente de Turkle
force prend fin en 2041 il veut préparer
la suite mettez un œil labrador écorché
depuis 1969 et sur ses gardes
[Musique]
quel gouvernement de négocier une
entente qui sera acceptée par la
population en raison de cette amertume
explique
de la justice dans le gouvernement de
Brain pegford dans les années 80
je crois que c'est un moment historique
pour nous dit le Premier ministre de
Terre-Neuve et Labrador Enzo Fiori mais
prudent il va négocier selon la vie des
experts
optimiste
pour tous et peut-être que cet animosité
va disparaître ajouter on peut
s'entendre avec le Québec ici Michel
Brideau Radio-Canada Saint-Jean